[Musica]
sedi di coorte greca qual è la prima
cosa che vi viene in mente
maestosi templi che scintillano al sole
o forse lega tinti statue di marmo
bianco beh non avete tutti i torti
perché la maggior parte delle
testimonianze dell'arte antica
sopravvissuta ha perso la sua
caratteristica più importante e cioè il
colore è difficile da credere ma
anticamente il colore era presente in
abbondanza
poi con lo scorrere del tempo con le
piogge con tutte le cose diciamo
naturali gli eventi naturali il colore
si è perso ma non nell ipogeo dei
cristallini e allora vi porto con me
andiamo a napoli nel quartiere sanita un
quartiere popolare un quartiere pieno di
gente di colori di fruttivendoli di
umore ed entriamo in un palazzo nel
palazzo che era stato del barone di
donato
sì perché lì anticamente vivevano
diciamo c'era la nobiltà napoletana
e infatti nel palazzo troviamo ancora lo
stemma di famiglia
entriamo dentro mi porto in un cortile
pieno di gente di stendini panni stesi
uccellini macchine caos
apcom portone un portone antico con una
grande chiave di ferro e vi porto con me
in un mondo ma così antico da tornare
indietro di 2300 anni scendiamo giù per
le scale scegliamo undici metri la
temperatura si abbassa i rumori iniziano
a non sentirsi più perdiamo la luce e vi
porto giù e arriviamo nell'ipogeo dei
cristallini una delle rare testimonianze
di arte funebre funeraria greca al mondo
e si li il vagone di donato nel 1889 nel
suo palazzo cercando acqua o tuffo o
forse per una sua intuizione
trovo questa meraviglia tombe funerale
completamente dipinte con il corredo
funebre intatto una meraviglia assoluta
sono quattro cappelle funerarie sulla
strada che era la strada antica un tempo
a cielo aperto oggi poggerà è una delle
quattro spicca sicuramente per la sua
meraviglia la famosa tomba c con la
medusa e dioniso arianna una meraviglia
assoluta che quando gli archeologi
vengono a vederla hanno reazioni
incredibili e
da descrivere e difficile nella sua
bellezza ci sono colori vibranti tutti i
colori che si sono persi nel mondo li
ritroviamo in abbondanza troviamo il blu
egizio il rosso magenta il giallo ocra
scultura cielo aperto un tempo questo
era un pezzo di tufo che i greci hanno
scolpito scegliendo quella parte della
città come necropoli e queste tombe sono
completamente scolpite nel tufo e
all'interno troviamo addirittura doppi
cuscini come per simulare arredi e
meravigliose meravigliose testimonianze
anche con grafiche dell'arte greca ma io
che ci faccio nelle tombe greche nel
quartiere sanità di napoli
mio marito giampio dell'erede del barone
di donato ha ereditato questa meraviglia
e la sempre tenuta chiusa perché è
talmente preziosa che si è sempre
preferito tenere chiuso questo sito
archeologico così importante evitare
appunto di danneggiare queste pitture
io vado a vivere a milano per dieci anni
in cui dieci anni mi mancava tantissimo
la mia città pensiamo sempre alla mia
città e diceva mio marito io ho un sogno
voglio tornare a napoli e aprire
l'ipogeo di cristallini al pubblico
un'operazione complessa diciamo
impossibile per me che sono
niente non sono né archeologa e storica
dell'arte
ma era proprio forte di me questo
desiderio di tornare a napoli e fare
qualcosa per la mia città qualcosa che
potesse aiutare la mia città a rialzarsi
dai tanti problemi e troppo facile
andare via e quindi torno a vivere a
napoli partecipiamo un bando della
regione lo vinciamo arriviamo terzi
quindi vado dal mio marito e dicono
abbiamo vinto
che vogliamo fare e lui mi dice bene io
te lo affido ma mi raccomando devi avere
i migliori con te e quindi stipuliamo
con l'istituto centrale del restauro
ente massimo in italia una convenzione e
avendo naturalmente la sovrintendenza
che all alta sorveglianza sul bene avevo
vicino gli enti massimi mi sono sentita
subito al sicuro non capendo nulla di
archeologia evidente mi sono sentita
subito al sicuro abbiamo creato un
gruppo di lavoro molto
molto forte io devo dire non avevo bene
idea della sovrintendenza cosa fosse
perché
avevo un'idea distorta
invece poi abbiamo creato un gruppo di
lavoro
bellissimo e ho capito quanto loro
avessero a cuore la nostra cultura e
quanto luogo la potessero proteggere
nella maniera più autentica e corretta
possibile e quindi abbiamo lavorato
tanto sono quasi tre anni che lavoriamo
siamo tanti perché portare alla luce la
storia e dargli una nuova vita quella
luce che insieme a tutte quelle luci che
già sono state accese nel quartiere
sanità da padre loffredo e da tante
altre associazioni
noi speriamo possa ancora far brillare
di più questo quartiere e quindi noi
famiglia martuscelli insieme abbiamo
parlato abbiamo sempre detto noi non
siamo i proprietari di questo bene noi
siamo i custodi
perché i veri proprietari sono il
quartiere il quartiere insieme a tutto
il palazzo il palazzo di leonato che
l'ha protetto nei secoli e allora lo
vogliamo ridonare lo vogliamo ridonare
con un progetto sociale coinvolgendo
vogliamo far crescere i progetti dei
cristallini da solo senza di loro senza
il quartiere questo progetto non avrebbe
la stessa forza abbiamo creato forti
alleanze di amicizia di amore e
bellissimo e meraviglioso abbiamo già
assunto dei ragazzi del quartiere e
questo progetto sociale ha veramente per
noi è una sfida una sfida enorme perché
crediamo nella cultura che la cultura
può dare ovviamente alla città di napoli
al quartiere delle nuove opportunità il
24 giugno abbiamo aperto cioè anzi
abbiamo inaugurato apriremo tra due
giorni abbiamo assunto i ragazzi che
sono emozionatissimi abbiamo fatto un
inaugurazione meravigliosa e tutto il
mondo parla di noi ci hanno contattato
dai più dalle più grandi testate del
mondo dall assieme alla bbc national
geographic smithsonian hai tutte le reti
nazionali locali si è aperto un mondo un
mondo che io non avevo idea veramente
non sapevo
cioè non pensavo che potesse succedere
tutto questo ovviamente sono stata solo
spinta da questa fortissimo questo
fortissimo amore per la mia città un po
non ho tanto riflettuto perché
un'operazione nostra della famiglia e
quindi siamo andati avanti il 24 giugno
abbiamo aperto sono venuti anche vari
amici a trovarci e ci hanno regalato ci
hanno fatto un regalo è un regalo che io
non capivo perché sono questi due sassi
ce l'hanno regalati io non capivo detto
sì sono molto belli dopodiché ho preso
il biglietto
che loro ci hanno che ci hanno scritto
al loro capito il significato di questi
meravigliosi sassi
alessandria il tuo progetto è come un
sasso gettato nell'acqua immobile di uno
stagno che provoca una serie di piccole
onde che si allargano a cerchi
concentrici dando vita a una serie di
reazioni a catena che altrimenti non
sarebbero mai avvenute
grazie
[Applauso]